[Applaudissements]
écoutez ces préliminaires
attendez attendez vous allez posséder
juin dans les yeux sors ta langue
je lui met la main sur les tétons
elle frémit elle frémit elle frémit je
la sent frémir
elle s'approche elle s'approche elle
s'approche je lui saute pas dessus nous
sommes calmes nous sommes calmes mais je
la pénètre non réjouissances sera
simultanée soit dans la nuit elle aura
du plaisir c'est oui
[Applaudissements]
gilles g lombard est sa deuxième type
d'abus pour moi c'est alors attention
deuxième titre écouté dow jones sex bomb
écouter les basses écoutez les bases là
nous sommes dans le rythme des sexes là
c'est le sexe elle est sauvage elle aime
ça elle est sauvage elle courjault la
trappe
elle a une rampe patte de sous pas de
sauts je prends ça rentre je lis ça va
pas dans les eaux calmes et vous elle
vient sur moi elle vient sur moi elle
grimpe sur moi elles sont pâles sur mon
île encore hypnotisé
[Applaudissements]
maintenant la dernière à nikon annie
cordy me ferait mal une cérébrale une
coquine elle aime jouer au hockey les
joueuses on va jouer on va jouir d'un
jour à jouer elle s'échappe
elle s'échappe et le temps de l'échappée
je le rattrappe jeu la trappe sous son
grand chapeau je lui enlève ces cas
cette fois les femmes elles tentent de
s'échapper
je lui lève son chapeau et elle c'est
son âme que je baisserais
[Applaudissements]
la forêt